la semelle en paix sera particulièrement
festive cette année pour les commerçants
380 millions de dollars ces montants que
vont dépenser les québécois cette année
pour la fête de l'amour selon le conseil
québécois du commerce de détail 63 % des
québécois ont l'intention souligner la
saint valentin c'est un sommet en cinq
ans les dépenses atteindront 93 dollars
en moyenne par personne
une somme qui sera consacrée à des
sorties au restaurant une soirée
spectacle ou encore les traditionnels
chocolats bonbons et fleurs pour les
fleuristes cette journée d'ailleurs
l'une des plus rentables de l'année aux
états unis où les dépenses dépassent les
27 milliards de dollars seulement la
moitié de cette somme est utilisé pour
gâter d'êtres chers
le corps des américains achètent un
cadeau à leur animal de compagnie et 6%
à leurs collègues de travail
[Musique]